hello and welcome to the co playing
Dussel why they got that NM title now
we're okay first time that I see that
cool free taejeong okay so i'm going to
play this Bishop c5 setup curious once
you get an early night Jeff three ok so
we probably transpose to the main lines
yeah not yet played the knight to f6 I
don't think this this is a particular
impact at the moment one idea of this
water here is that if white plays with
92 then h5 can be an option um eh five
looks more like suited for um a bullet
game and best okay maybe I can develop
like this now okay so I was thinking if
night is seven is an alternative here to
just down very it a little bit into
Knight f6 but sure how to believe that
this could be better and the natural
move okay so quick before taking it Ruby
one doesn't help so I'm canceling
okay yeah I don't really see that b5 is
all that dangerous age success to have
the h7 square after later Bishop g6
night h4 maybe night age four and then
be five okay that I don't mind I mean c7
is not all that difficult a thing to
defend and they even have seized six not
sure about it but it's also possible so
I also could go f 54 f 4 and bring the
bishop to f7 okay that's an interesting
idea
okay grab that and we should be sick
this Knight to c4 i am i see i also have
f4 which i'm not sure of entirely but ok
it looks pretty active so let's do it
actually not you okay so interesting now
i have f 3 also here on a couple of good
moves now i have f 3 pushing this back
and i can take d5 right right after that
and it's hard to believe that this
shouldn't be good so let's take it queen
bee three address coking age eight or so
it doesn't doesn't really do much
now it looks excellent at least I don't
see anything great for him okay that
that makes my bishop a lot stronger but
also cuts this one I guess to e74 96-94
okay think I'll go here be ready for 94
I'm a little bit low on time no not a
lot but keep being a little bit slower
than my opponent him
yeah what if you like to put this piece
on d4 it would have been really nice
hmm yeah nothing great really okay I'm
gonna pull up but it's not so totally
cleaned win or anything like that time
morning
look you soon okay Queenie itís is ok
but I should have seen seen that before
hand
and now we can take a seven to give
three hey Andrew q1 is threatened shoot
with the care he overlooked in Bishop c4
Cooney 5 didn't quite get it was very
bad but still check check check check
check mate ok handsome up and down Sam
wasn't very precise yeah okay that
Bishop c5 those Bishop c5 setups they're
very very solid they're very solid for
black and can be played without the
usual amount of theoretical knowledge
all those moves are fairly natural em
defaults may be interesting but all this
is fairly normal yeah here g-49 age for
something that he could have tried being
very direct getting the bishops yeah
that's it's certainly an idea but this
before water was interesting i cannot
take after rupee one it it's pretty much
unavoidable then I lose that back and
well now then my position becomes
completely unstable so just playing on
the moves rather yeah I didn't really
feel 95 is all that dangerous here this
one shouldn't be bad yeah and I came up
with f5 and
actually gives f6 hmm okay I had this
idea to push the eff porn further so
yeah here f4 move yeah that cannot be
bad i think it should be rather annoying
for four wide I an hour here he I missed
something i miss thing so I mean that's
not new but it's here this is better of
course this is basically just losing
immediately if I win age three the
game's over okay now I didn't I didn't
spot that I mean I saw that this is
unprotected but I didn't see a direct
way of exploiting it also it was pretty
tempting to just take the center pond
all this 96 playing all the comp moves
and then this funky move yeah took with
this the computer wants to play this one
chimps that more precise I don't think
it's a big difference I mean here it's
really just a pawn yeah rube t7 now it's
running into a awkward self pin so it's
not a great idea yeah now counter
checking the corn
I already I didn't see that I had this
because the truck is protected this way
that wins very cleanly and i blundered
that one and he is to go look T 1
instead of this which loses everything
yeah and then it was quite easy yeah
tightly contested game I missed two
chances that were to make it a clean win
the way it went it was them it was less
clear ok well thanks for watching